Claude firestore is a server list no
sequel document database that simplifies
storing syncing and querying data for
your mobile and web apps at global scale
you may have heard the cloud fire store
is the next generation of cloud
datastore but what does that mean what
makes it different and what should you
do if you're an existing data store
customer
I'm Kevin Nelson find out answers to all
those questions and more in this video
let's get the question I always get
asked first
out of the way I want to start off by
assuring datastore users that all your
existing datastore applications will
continue to work under cloud fire store
running in datastore mode you won't have
to make any code changes and you'll
experience zero downtime when your
service is automatically upgraded after
cloud fire store becomes generally
available so with that out of the way
let's do a quick review of what
datastore is and then I'll get into the
new capabilities being introduced in
cloud fire store Google Cloud datastore
is a fully managed no sequel document
database built for automatic scaling
high performance and ease of application
development it was introduced with
Google App Engine Google's original
serverless development platform that
today handles the toughest workloads
from some of the world's most popular
apps cloud fire store builds on the
features and massive scalability of
datastore while adding several important
new features the first thing to
understand is that cloud firestar runs
in two mutually exclusive modes
datastore mode and native mode in
datastore mode cloud fire store runs all
your existing datastore applications and
eliminates some of datastores
restrictions cloud fire store is built
on an entirely new back-end that brings
the best of Google clouds powerful cloud
infrastructure to existing datastore
applications this includes strong
consistency automatic multi-region data
replication atomic batch operations and
transaction support perhaps even better
cloud forest or completely eliminates
the entity group transaction limits that
were present in datastore cloud fire
store has no entity groups and therefore
no entity group limits
you get all of these new capabilities
and compatibility with datastore when
running cloud fire store in datastore
mode cloud fire store native mode has
all the advantages of datastore mode but
also contains a number of new features
that make it easier to power native
mobile and web apps including robust
multi device synchronization full
offline support and a comprehensive set
of client libraries which support an
integrated storage solution across
Google App Engine kubernetes and mobile
devices you can learn more about this
using the link to my left it's important
to understand though that cloud fire
store native mode isn't compatible with
existing data store applications you'll
have to setup a new project with a new
cloud fire store database if you want to
use native mode in either mode cloud
fire store is a truly serverless
database service that eliminates the
need to think about spinning up virtual
machines data replication or scaling
should your app hit the first page of
tech name and suddenly grow from
hundreds of QPS
to millions cloud fire store will
automatically scale to handle that surge
in traffic and congratulations the data
model and cloud fire store native mode
is similar to the data store data model
but there are a few differences data in
cloud fire stores organized into
documents and collections which are
similar to entities and kinds in
datastore
at the highest level a cloud fire store
database can have any number of
collections which contain any number of
documents a document contains a group of
key value pairs called fields in fire
store similar to properties in datastore
documents can also contain sub
collections of additional documents
notice the alternating pattern of
collections and documents your
collections and documents must always
follow this pattern
you cannot reference a collection in a
collection or a document within a
document
managing indexes in cloud fire store is
also a little different than how they're
managed in datastore like datastore
cloud fire store requires an index for
every query fire store automatically
creates an index for every document
field
compound queries require that you first
create a composite index that maps to
the range clause of your query these are
easy to manage directly from the
firestore console you'll even be
prompted to create the composite index
the first time you attempt to query that
doesn't have an existing index when you
create a new cloud firestore database
you'll select which mode you want either
datastore mode or firestore native mode
consider this choice carefully because
you won't be able to change the mode
once the database has been created as I
mentioned earlier to take full advantage
of all the new capabilities of cloud
firestorm like offline support and
device synchronization existing data
store users will need to set up a new
project with a new database in fire
store native mode this was a very basic
introduction to the cloud fire store
data model you can learn more in my
colleague Todd Kerpelman video series
gets a no cloud fire store on the Google
cloud YouTube channel and online at
cloud google.com slash fire store there
you can learn all about cloud fire
stores schema-less data model and
advanced query capabilities ok so now
you're probably asking yourself fire
store sounds great but what does it
really mean for my existing application
using data store great question
during beta data store customers or
really anyone can try out fire store by
creating a fire store database in a new
project select fire store under the
storage options in the GCP console if
you want to move existing data into fire
store you can do so using the managed
export and import service once cloud
fire store has been launched for general
availability all data store projects
will be automatically migrated to fire
store running in data store mode the
upgrade will be done automatically for
you with no downtime and no changes to
your application absolutely no action is
required on your part migrating all data
store customers will likely take a few
months you'll be notified when your
migration is scheduled to begin if that
time isn't convenient or you have a
critical time window where you don't
want your application to possibly be
impacted by the automatic migration say
Black Friday you'll be able to indicate
preference
via Google form but again you shouldn't
notice any differences at all during or
after migration so now you may be
wondering whether your next project
should be built using cloud firestore in
datastore mode or native mode in general
we recommend building new applications
in native mode so your app can take
advantage of all fire source
capabilities but keep in mind that
during the beta period cloud fires to
our won't have an SLA and cloud fire
store in native mode may have some
restrictions on the number of concurrent
connections and the maximum number of
writes per second those caps may rise as
we get closer to GA refer to the
documentation for the latest details
so cloud fire store in native mode lets
you take advantage of fire stores full
capabilities but may not be appropriate
for large mission-critical enterprise
applications until cloud fire store goes
GA so to recap cloud fire store is the
next generation of data store all
existing data store databases will be
migrated to cloud fire store running in
data store mode beginning shortly after
general availability that migration will
be automatic and seamless fire store in
native mode adds powerful new
capabilities for web and mobile
developers like comprehensive client
libraries offline support and automatic
device synchronization I hope this video
has given you a better idea about some
of the new capabilities of fire store
and what it means for your existing data
store applications you can find lots
more information about fire store on the
Google cloud youtube channel and in the
online docs you'll find those links
right next to me thanks for listening
[Music]